from trick-or-treating to dressing up
for a killer costume party
you can always count on seeing at least
a few disney characters in the crowd
we are looking at you ariel which got us
thinking who would our disney favorites
dress up as if they had the chance
we wanted to see where our favorite
princes princesses heroes and heroines
would find
inspo when they get ready for halloween
in the magic kingdom
bring on the wigs colored contacts props
face paint
and super powers who rocks a super cute
couple's costume
which princess stuns in a spooky outfit
and makeup look
and which heroine becomes a demigod keep
watching my pretties
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mirror mirror on the wall who had the
most striking look of them all
was your favorite a trick or a treat did
you imagine them as a different
fictional character
let us know in the comment section down
below then don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to the things for
more fun videos just like this
happy halloween
you